-Here we are!
-BTS!
-And our new song starts in...
-5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
-Whoo!
-Boom.
-♪ It's the thought
of being young ♪
♪ When your heart's
just like a drum ♪
♪ Beating louder
with no way to guard it ♪
-♪ When it all seems like
it's wrong ♪
♪ Sing along with Elton John ♪
♪ To that feeling,
we're just getting started ♪
-♪ When the nights get colder ♪
♪ And the rhythm's
got you falling behind ♪
-♪ Just dream
about that moment ♪
♪ When you look yourself
right in the eye, eye, eye ♪
♪ Then you say ♪
-♪ I wanna dance ♪
♪ The music's got me going ♪
♪ Ain't nothing that can stop
how we move, yeah ♪
-♪ Let's break our plans and
live just like we're golden ♪
♪ And roll in
like we're dancing fools ♪
-♪ We don't need to worry ♪
♪ 'Cause when we fall,
we know how to land ♪
-♪ Don't need to talk the talk,
just walk the walk tonight ♪
-♪ 'Cause we don't need
permission to dance ♪
-♪ There's always something
that's standing in the way ♪
♪ But if you don't
let it faze ya ♪
♪ You'll know
just how to break ♪
♪ Just keep the right ♪
-♪ Vibe, yeah ♪
♪ 'Cause there's
no looking back ♪
♪ There ain't no one to prove ♪
♪ We don't got this on lock ♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
-♪ The wait is over ♪
♪ The time is now,
so let's do it right, mm ♪
-♪ Yeah, we'll keep going ♪
♪ And stay up until we see
the sunri-i-ise and we'll say ♪
-♪ I wanna dance,
the music's got me going ♪
♪ Ain't nothing that can stop
how we move, yeah ♪
-♪ Let's break our plans and
live just like we're golden ♪
♪ And roll in
like we're dancing fools ♪
-♪ We don't need to worry ♪
♪ 'Cause when we fall,
we know how to land ♪
-♪ Don't need to talk the talk,
just walk the walk tonight ♪
-♪ 'Cause we don't need
permission to dance ♪
-♪ Da-na-na-na-na-na-na,
da-na-na-na-na-na-na ♪
♪ Da-na-na-na-na-na-na ♪
-♪ No, we don't need
permission to dance ♪
-♪ Da-na-na-na-na-na-na ♪
-♪ Hey ♪
-♪ Da-na-na-na-na-na-na,
da-na-na-na-na-na-na ♪
♪♪
-♪ Well, let me show ya ♪
♪ That we can keep
the fire alive, mm ♪
-♪ 'Cause it's not over ♪
♪ Till it's over,
say it one more time ♪
♪ Say ♪
-♪ I wanna dance ♪
♪ The music's got me going ♪
-♪ The music's got me going ♪
-♪ Ain't nothing
that can stop how we move ♪
♪ Hey, yeah ♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
-♪ Let's break our plans ♪
♪ And live
just like we're golden ♪
♪ And roll in
like we're dancing fools ♪
-♪ Like we're dancing fools ♪
-♪ We don't need to worry ♪
♪ 'Cause when we fall,
we know how to land ♪
-♪ We know how to land ♪
-♪ Don't need to talk the talk ♪
♪ Just walk the walk tonight ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ 'Cause we don't need
permission to dance ♪
-♪ Da-na-na-na-na-na-na,
da-na-na-na-na-na-na ♪
♪ Da-na-na-na-na-na-na ♪
-♪ No, we don't need
permission to dance ♪
-♪ Da-na-na-na-na-na-na,
da-na-na-na-na-na-na ♪
♪ Da-na-na-na-na-na-na ♪
-♪ 'Cause we don't need
permission to dance ♪
-♪ Da-na-na-na-na-na-na,
da-na-na-na-na-na-na ♪
♪ Da-na-na-na-na-na-na ♪
-♪ No, we don't need
permission to dance ♪
-♪ Da-na-na-na-na-na-na,
da-na-na-na-na-na-na ♪
♪ Da-na-na-na-na-na-na ♪
-♪ 'Cause we don't need
permission to dance ♪
-Whoo!